hey little guys my name is a cello and
walked back to my skipper but series and
today I'm going to be talking all about
strings in C++ too many years that you
should watch if you haven't already are
the pointers videos video and pointers
and the last week's video rather two
days ago video which was on about arrays
because as we're about to discover trims
very much tied with arrays so first of
all what is a string in general a string
is essentially a group of characters by
characters I mean letters numbers
symbols that kind of stuff it's
basically tacked so it's very very
common for us as humans of course to
want to represent text in some in some
way shape or form on our computers so it
has this problem of well my programming
we want to be able to represent text and
that kind of group of text it could be a
single character it could be an entire
paragraph it could be a single word it
could be a bunch of words all that stuff
that's called string it's a string of
text so we need some way to be able to
represent that in our program and that
what a string in table cloth is it's a
way for us to actually be able to
represent and manipulate that text so if
you understand how strings work which is
really we're going to talk about I mean
in this type of foot series you know
that I like to kind of go in depth and
to share with you guys how things
actually work because like for me
personally when I'm learning something
new I really really like to understand
how it actually works that helps me
understand the way that I can use it
because if you just tell me what I
should do
the type string of code for example
that's cool like I know what a string is
however in the future when I run into
something and I'm not sure if it all
work or not if I know how the underlying
technology works I can kind of make make
an educated guess and determine whether
or not what I'm trying to do is is
impossible in the first place so you
want to standing up strings work in C++
you first need to understand how
characters works and what what
characters actually are so characters
being things like letters in book
numbers they're represented in various
forms and this is not going to be a
tutorial or or a video about
different kind of character encoding
systems that we have in the world
because there are probably too many to
count and they're all very complicated
and they're all very kind of depending
on what what the specification actually
is so wherever you get to in depth about
that maybe in a future video but we are
going to talk about how characters work
in general now you may have noticed
already that there is a data type in C++
called char which is shot to character
and so far we've kind of used it with
the reference of this is one byte of
memory and so it's useful for being able
to do things like cut pointers into a
child pointer so you can do pointer
arithmetic in terms of bias it's also
useful for allocating memory buffers
because if you want allocate if you want
to allocate one kilobyte of memory you
can dissipate 1,024 charts and there you
go
but it's also very useful for strength
and test because the way it is people
put treats characters by default release
ASCII characters again text encoding not
trying to get into that in this video
but the way that we kind of deal with
characters in C++ is in the form that
the character is won by it and that is
what ASCII is that extended asking is a
lot of other than utf-8 utf-16 you have
to - we have things like Y strings and
we have we have of course character
tested in which characters a way above
won by it we are - by characters 3 by 4
by characters with other languages such
as Japanese or Chinese or languages that
actually have different characters than
the ones we see in English we need to be
able to use them because they're simply
anointeth code if we only have one byte
to represent a character that 8 bits
which means we have 2 to the power of 8
possibilities of what that number would
be which is 256 possibilities there are
way more than 256 characters if you take
into account English letters numbers
symbol you know Japanese letters Korean
letters all that kind of stuff so we
can't fit all languages into you know a
fifth character set that wouldn't work
so we have like utf-16 for example which
is a 16-bit character encoding which
means that we have to have 16 different
possibilities which is 65536 to four
characters we have all these other
things but in C++ just didn't say sign
language without any library kind of
uses just the primitive data type char
is one byte which is why when you use a
string as we're about to in C++ not a
wide string which is two bytes per
character but a normal string with which
uses a normal child of each character
we're talking about 1 by characters and
we're primarily talking about just being
able to do English if you're going to
need to do some other language such as
Russian you're not gonna be able to do
that using this you you and have to use
some kind of different character
occurring which we've talked about other
languages and all that in the future but
interesting to talk about strings
because strings and text and and all
that stuff and maybe later into the game
engine font rendering is actually a
hugely complicated problem that the most
people overlook just text in general and
language is isn't massive massively
complicated problem ok so that's a
pretty big introduction but let's talk
about how things actually work in a C++
characters I mentioned characters I
mentioned the char data type a string is
basically an array of characters that's
why I want you guys to watch that arrays
video in the description everywhere a
string is just an array of characters
and array being a sort of set of
elements so we have a quarter set of
characters which make up a string of
text you may have noticed in the series
that we've often referred to strings of
char pointers so let's take a look at
how that works we can declare a space
start string by writing const char
pointer the name of the string like name
and then setting it equal to in double
quote some kind of text so we'll set it
equal to china for example this is
essentially a c style way of defining
strengths because we do have a library
in C++ which means which makes string
operations much much easier for us than
this but it's still important to kind of
know how to work so that you know how to
take off both version work you also
don't need to declare it as comped char
but the reason people usually do that is
because you really don't want to be
going around and changing the value of
these strings are immutable in the sense
that you can't just extend a string and
make it bigger because this is a fixed
allocated block of memory if you want to
have a bigger string you need to perform
a brand new allocation and delete the
old string now just because this is a
child pointer does not mean this is
actually here allocated you do not
delete these things by either calling
the lease name
or delete name or anything like that we
haven't talked about new and delete and
all this kind of heap allocation stuff
I've added stuff coming very very soon I
know that we need to get into this but
the rule of thumb is just if you don't
use the new keyword don't use the delete
keyword so in this case we made this
sure no string we didn't write new child
something like that we just wrote oh no
so no delete required if you do declare
cons that of course means that you can't
change the content of this again we'll
have a comp with you in the future but
you cannot for example change the third
character here which is the letter e to
be something like a you won't be able to
do that because you might just comps so
if you know that you're not going to
modify the strange market its Const
otherwise you can just leave it as a
child pointer that's totally fine okay
so the next question is cool this is a
string what does this look like in
memory and how long is that going to
work so we'll set a breakpoint over here
and just get a spider on our program so
that we can look at the memory that
makes up name if I go to my memory view
over here and type in name it's already
points as soon as I enter you can see
that we have a bunch of memory here and
if you look over here we have the word
check so what this side of the memory
view is is basically an ASCII
representation of this these are all
individual bytes and this is what that
by it would be if you convert it into
ASCII you can check out a certain
website such as ASCII table comm which
has a table of what those ASCII codes
actually are you can see in this case we
have 43 this is in hexadecimal so if we
go to the head column here find 43 you
can see that it corresponds to a capital
letter C that's what you see over here
that's the first letter of China now
hearing all these other strings which
are basically debug only helpers you can
see that we have those six characters
which make up the word Chan oh and then
we have advice that is set to zero this
is called the null termination character
that is how we know that that is where
the string ends you'll note that we
never we don't know what the size of
China is we can't it's just a pointer
right so how can we find out what the
size is that's where that null
termination character comes in a string
begins as that pointer at that memory
address and then it continues on until
it hits zero
that's how when we decide to print this
out to the console for example we can
write a the our name if I were to rerun
this you consider we get shown and print
into the console and yet it's just a
pointer so how does it know where it
ends it runs into that zero and it
realizes okay that's my null termination
character that at the end of the string
if you were to declare this by yourself
that's our example I create a other
string called name too
I'm going to do is it's fully manually
so I'll just make a new char array to 36
characters and then I think I'm a not
going to initialize it right here
I'll set it equal to the individual
characters characters and see what works
by the way I define with a single quote
not double quotes if it's double quotes
then by default it becomes a child
pointer okay not a string a child
pointer will get into strings in a
minute we have c h e RN r now this is an
array not a string right just an array
of six characters you can see there's
Nord null termination character so by
trying to print name to to the convoy
attack so we can we can expect the
memory as well but we'll Princeton will
print it to the console here you can see
that we get 0 and then a whole bunch of
random characters which is again the ask
interpretation of whatever the memory
was a name to we go back to this memory
view and type in name to you can see
that we have a bunch we have our Cherno
written and then a bunch of weird
characters which is you can see the
memory set to CC which are actually
array guys to let us know that that that
memory is outside of our location
whenever we allocate arrays and memory
in debug mode
we lost the debug version of the C
standard library the standard library
virtually the things like start guides
so that we know we know that we know
when we're right outside of the bounds
of our allocation again for me for
another video so because we don't have
that zero here at CDC ours does not
actually know when to and printing which
is why we get this random thing here
however if we were to expand it and
write 0 either expressed as as a
backslash 0 which is the actual ASCII
character if we go back to the ASCII
table you can see that the null is what
it actually is that how you declare a
null you write a backslash 0 the errors
we've got seven characters now right or
you can literally write the numeric
constant zero as well because that is
the actual value of this if we hit our
five you can see now we're printer know
properly with nothing else
that's how char arrays work that's how
string basically works that's what
string is it's a collection of
characters I think that I think that's
probably deep enough if you have any
other questions about how that actually
works
just leave the comment below I'll try
and answer as many as I can I don't I
think I've mentioned everything ok so a
simple plot how does paper Club come
into this and how should we be actually
making strings in c plus plus the
standard library in C++ has a class
called string it actually has a class
called basic string which is a template
class and STD colon colon string is
basically a templated version of that
basic string class which is templated
with charge but it's a it's a template
specialization that's what I'm looking
for of the basic string class with char
as the template parameter which means
charge the underlying data type for each
character so that is really what you
should be using there is something
called W string which is the wire
strength again we're not going to talk
about that we're going to be real simple
here STD string is what you should be
using to strengthen C++ how does Hanna
string actually work basically it is
it's just that it's a char array so it's
an array of chars and a bunch of
functions built-in manipulators later on
in this series when we start talking
about data structures we're actually
going to write our own data structures
so all the people floss all the kind of
people's data structures that you see in
a standard template library we're going
to manually write our own version of
that and see how and see how that works
and how we can optimize and all that
stuff so it stick around for that you're
interested but for now it's just a child
point it's basically just an array of
characters and functions built
immediately like that so let's talk
about how we can use Center strengths
okay the best turn our programs will
change this current set up to use a
standard string so the first thing we
need to do is include strength iostream
actually does have a definition to
string calibers once we always print it
to the console as we'll see in a minute
actually need to include the string
header file will change this child
pointer to be an STD string and that's
actually it we're done
string has a constructor that actually
takes in a child pointer or a comp child
pointer if you hover your mouse over
this you'll see that it is actually a
Const our array not a char array that's
one thing that I forgot to mention when
talk about conch-shell pointers that's
why you typically assign it to the
concho pointer because insert the child
pointer because intrinsically it is when
you define strings by literally double
quotes in a word or multiple words in
people but it's actually concentrate not
just the char array but again any put
the card to a child pointer if you need
to manipulate the contents of the
strength totally fine so printing this
again we can just call name - you can
see that there's a lot clearer than
having a conch our pointer if we hit f5
you can see it works the same way now if
I hadn't included this string header
file and just dealt with iostream you
can see we get an error on this output
stream operators telling us that we
cannot send a string into the center to
be our output string because the
overload for this operator that allows
us to push string in there is inside
that is inside this header file okay
that's why I included string even though
iostream actually does have a
destination border and of course because
this is a proper class with a bunch of
functions we actually have all these
methods such as name dot size we can
find out what the size is if we just had
a constant our pointer or a child
pointer we would actually have to use
big functions like sterling which is the
length of the string and to copy for
example to copy strings and all this
stuff we have the function defined for
up inside shrink us which makes it
lovely that is how we use strings now I
know this Homer thing that you might
find yourself doing its appending
strings I want to do Cherno plus hello
or something like that
now you might get errors here the reason
this is happening is because you're
actually trying to add to column chart
arrays right this double quote is kind
of thing is a contra array it's not not
an actual string or it's not a strength
you can't just add two points together
dozen or two arrays together doesn't
work that way so if you want to do
something like this a nice easy way to
do that is either with this up into
multiple lines because
now you're doing name plus equals colors
so what you're doing is you're adding a
pointer to an actual name which is a
string you're adding it to a string and
plus equal is overloaded in the string
class to be able to let you to let you
do that or one thing that I do quite
often as well is just threw out one of
them with the strings instructor for you
explicitly calling a string constructor
so you're making a string out it is and
then appending that to it as well and
that will be totally fine sure this way
you might end up with more copies but
for most reason looks like for most
purposes it's fine if you want to find
text in string you can use name dot fine
and then these string of text that you
want to look for for example I want to
look for the note inside
Cherno hello so I'll do named offline
node if that does not equal strip SP or
the educated E string and pods which is
basically an illegal position for that
fine then it contains that noticing
because what name dot find actually
returns is the position of this test so
in this case it will return the position
of the beginning of this so if you just
want to see if it contains something or
not you use this because there's no
actual dot contained function anyway I
could go on and describe the entire
string API to you I've linked HTTP
reference kind of link to strengthen it
in the description below so you can
check that out if you want to see
everything that that string cloud office
but yes that strings super easy to use
we'll be using them a lot in the future
and another series that I'm maybe going
to start soon wink so yes that's pretty
much all there is to it one other thing
that I want to quickly mention is
passing these strings around to other
functions if I write if I wrote a
function called print string and I
wanted to be able to pass a string
around I would not simply write a city
string string and then have my
university our strength the reason I
wouldn't do this is because then it's
actually a copy we haven't talked about
this too much but when you pass in a
class like this to a function what
you're actually doing is you're creating
a brand you're creating a copy of that
class of that object and giving it to
this function so if I then was to do
something like string class equals a
short
it wouldn't affect the original string
that was passed in say over here however
this is clearly a read-only function
we're not gonna be modifying anything we
just want to print it so why would we
copy an entire string copying a string
means we have to dynamically on the heat
allocate the brand-new char array to
store that exact same text that we've
already got that's not fast string
copying is actually really quite close
apparently and it's if it's the major
short point in some cases because string
operations are so common so whenever you
pass a string like this and it's going
to be read-only make sure you pass it by
cons preference okay so we'll add Const
over here at the front and reference
what that tells us is that we this is a
reference meaning that it won't get
copied and constant means we're
promising not to modify it here again I
said promising because technically we
could override dates we wanted to but of
course we're we're promising not to so
we're going to we're going to deny I'll
have a video in the future about cause
references are more kind of feature
video because there's a lot to them and
there's a few tricks that we can talk
about but that is basically what strings
are do you guys enjoy this video make
sure you hit that like button if you
really enjoy this series and you want to
see more videos like this you can
support me on patreon account for
special channel there's a really nice
community we've got going on slack I'm
actually thinking maybe switching to
this court because I think patreon
offers discord rewards and kind of it's
all built-in so it might be a bit set up
but basically to place a certain amount
you get access to trust videos as well
as a like a discussion thread in which
we can actually talk about what goes
into these videos and plan it together
that's pretty cool and of course it
helps me make more videos which is
always good if you have any questions
about this episode or about strings or
anything you can just leave a comment
below I'll try to reply to as many as I
can in this video I find it's a bit a
bit more easy with the kind of money
script anything as much this was more of
a casual kind of conversation let me
know what you think of these kind of
videos they kind of make it a bit
rambling looking at the time here and a
lot has passed but I kind of like these
more laid back videos there be easy for
me to make as well I know I don't think
I'm stressed because I'd like to
Melbourne now and I'm going to work
every day and coming home and just
having our conversation with the camera
probably means that I can probably
release more than one video a week which
is which is which is good so let me know
what you think about that in the
comments below and I'll see you guys
later
good bye
[Music]
[Music]